notre séquence un jour avec qui démarre
avec vous disait jean marc collienne en
direct de paris au philharmonique paris
oui la philharmonie de paris vous la
voyez ça derrière moi ce magnifique
bâtiment vous voyez c'est un véritable
temple de la musique qui a été libéré en
2015 aux portes de paris dans le parc de
la villette c'est ici que les enfants du
projet demos se produiront demain soir
les 79 petits réunionnais nous les avons
suivis pendant toute cette semaine à
paris notamment vous savez les deux
soeurs carwin et caixa qu'on vous avait
présenté la semaine dernière dans un
jour avec
elles font partie des 79 ans qui se
produiront demain elles ont reçu un
instrument comme tous les autres il y a
trois or elles ont appris la musique
toutes les semaines dans leur quartier
pendant ces trois ans tout ça
gratuitement car c'est l'idée
l'idée c'est vraiment d'amener à la
musique des enfants des quartiers qui
autrement n'auraient jamais eu la
possibilité demain soir jean-marc tous
ces enfants vont donner un concert dans
une salle extraordinaire
oui car eux quand vous allez voir quand
on rentre dans la philharmonie dans ya
ce bâtiment incroyable à cette colline
d'aluminium en direct quand on rentre
comme les enfants ont pu le faire cette
semaine on découvre une salle
extraordinaire une salle de concert
c'est une salle de 2400 places qui a été
conçu par le célèbre architecte jean
nouvel avec une acoustique
exceptionnelle demain soir ce sont donc
les petits réunionnais qui seront sur
cette grande sur cette grande scène
ils ont eu l'occasion d'y répété
mercredi pendant tout le week-end
ce sont des orchestres demos venus de
toute la france qui vont s'y succéder
car ce projet développé partout en
france il y actuellement 35 orchestre
demos au total trois mille six cents
enfants qui vivent cette belle aventure
musicale
c'est une belle aventure musicale on le
voit mais c'est aussi pour les enfants
la réunion un très beau voyage en marque
oui une formidable découverte il faut
dire que la plupart des enfants
n'avaient jamais quitté la réunion
beaucoup n'avaient jamais pris l'avion
et là il découvre paris une découverte
exceptionnelle je peux vous dire que
c'est aussi une sacrée aventure à voyage
à paris avec 79 ans pour ceux qui les
encadrent les animateurs de la cité des
arts et puis les référents sociaux qui
les accompagnent depuis trois ans
prendre le tram à l'heure de pointe avec
autant d'enfants des instruments aussi
gros qu'un violoncelle c'est pas simple
les enfants ont ainsi pu découvrir la
tour eiffel les champs elysées bien sûr
nous on a eu droit à une journée au parc
astérix mais ils ont aussi découvert
d'autres grands lieux de la musique
comme l'opéra garnier ce matin là aussi
l'objectif du projet des mots c'est
d'amener les enfants dans des lieux
qu'ils n'auraient sans doute jamais
visiter autrement je vous pose entendre
d'ailleurs sharmila et chelsea c'était
ce matin à l'heure du pique nique dans
le jardin des tuileries est évoqué ce
que ce projet demos leur a apporté
j'ai découvert aussi d'autres personnes
car y est on a qui passe est un peu
triste mais ça nous a fait des amitiés
et découvrir
la musique classique
ce qu'il y a
des gens qui n'aiment pas la musique
classique il est des commentaires tu
fais ça alors que safran c'est quoi la
musique classique
moi je trouve que c'est original classe
apaisant voilà c'est une chance parce
que
si une expérience à vivre et c'est pas
tous les enfants qui gagne cette chance
folle je note une expérience à défaut
d'autres enfants qui vont faire des
pauses idées et demain soir jean-marc ce
sera la fin de l' aventure pour ces 79
marmailles du projet demos
pas tout à fait et ce thème parce
qu'après ça durera encore après le grand
concert demain soir il dort encore un
grand concert à découvrir d'ailleurs
pour tous ceux qui le veulent début
juillet le 3 juillet à la cité des arts
de saint denis et puis surtout c'est
important les enfants qui aura envie de
poursuivre la musique
il rentre goût ils pourront le faire il
pourra d'ailleurs conservé l'instrument
qui leur a été confiée est allé dans des
écoles de musique
en attendant puisque c'est la fête de la
musique propose de vous laisser avec un
extrait du ballet de debussy que des
enfants réunionnais joueront demain soir
parc
[Musique]
on
en
oui
h
et les dimanches soir jean marc
collienne et philippe hoareau nous
proposerons un reportage sur le concert
des enfants réunionnais ensuite ce sont
d'autres enfants qui seront accueillis
dans le projet demos puisque les
communes de la cinor ont décidé de
continuer à financer le projet et
peut-être d'autres communes de la
réunion voilà reportage dimanche soir